While It brought some much-needed life back
to the box office after a disappointing summer,
Darren Aronofsky's Mother is the first casualty
of the fall after opening to just $7.5 million.
The hard-to-define film stars Jennifer Lawrence
as the title character, wife to Javier Bardem's
"Him", as a woman who must deal with the
increasing stress of unwanted visitors entering
her once-peaceful home.
The film's vague log line has been a topic
of discussion for months, and the movie became
even more shrouded in mystery as confusing
trailers and TV spots hit the airwaves.
While Mother was as hard to track as it was
to explain, no one expected the film to fall
as far as it did.
Let's take a look at why Mother has had trouble
finding an audience.
Critical division
While the Rotten Tomatoes score on Mother
isn't terrible, critics were certainly divided
over how good … or bad Mother is.
Some reviewers hailed the film for its visual
brilliance, while others were left confused
and frustrated, calling the pic pretentious
and nonsensical.
"I don't like it that people booed.
I'm not a masochist, but I want a reaction
from people."
Although Aronofsky's movies have been widely
respected, and even his best works are hard
to watch twice, Mother reviews indicated it
might be hard to watch even once.
Some accused the writer-director of trying
to mix in too much allegory and extremism
to the film to endure.
Others thought it was bleak just for the sake
of it.
And almost everyone agreed that a screening
of Mother is an intense, bewildering, and
disturbing experience.
Moviegoers obviously enjoyed the light thrill
of seeing a movie like It, where the scares
are comparatively wholesome.
But audiences obviously weren't as interested
in traveling down another of Aronofsky's existential
wormholes this weekend.
And even those who did see it were unimpressed.
It was the opening night audience that earned
the film the rare distinction of an F rating
on CinemaScore.
Mother isn't the first film from a director
to get the dreaded rating.
Steven Soderbergh's Solaris also holds that
distinction, so some consider it a badge of
honor.
But it's still surprising to see a film with
a director and actors of this caliber be so
thoroughly docked by audiences.
Mixed marketing
Given its difficult premise, almost no one
goes into Mother really knowing what it's
about in advance.
Part of the reason for that is reviewers have
had such a tough time explaining what happened
even after seeing the movie.
And despite Google searches for explanation
spiking after the film's release, the results
for such queries can be just as confusing
as the movie itself.
Audiences may often enjoy twisty films, but
the biggest problem with Mother seems to be
that no one can agree on the true meaning.
Is this all just a cautionary tale on climate
change?
Is the title character really just Mother
Earth who's being abused by Javier Bardem's
God/Devil hybrid and all the terrible people
that flock to him?
Or is it a parable about the Bible's creation
story, with Jennifer Lawrence's character
as some kind of Eve?
No one can be quite sure.
"We are all living on this planet with this
one mother who gave us life."
Given that Aronofsky's last movie Noah was
based on the bible and did well in the international
box office, it might've seemed like a good
idea to continue on the theological train.
But the fact that no one's quite sure what
Mother is trying to represent makes it a very
difficult sell.
Bait and switch
While Jennifer Lawrence's fans might've been
shocked by seeing her ditch that defiant persona
that has informed so much of her career so
far, general audiences were probably more
surprised by how little horror the movie contains.
The original teasers for Mother made the film
seem like a horror movie, which is what earned
some serious interest prior to release.
The film's trailer drew out some of the film's
biggest scares, using the sounds of a ticking
clock to underscore what seemed to be a psychologically
focused haunted house movie.
Even Aronofsky himself insisted it was meant
to be a scare.
"It began with me wanting to get back to the
horror genre I did in Black Swan."
However, in the end, that genre identification
effort backfired, because Mother is definitely
not your usual Halloween fare.
Instead, the movie delves into the human psyche,
albeit with some very freaky imagery.
While those who were familiar with Aronofsky's
prior work might not have been surprised by
that, those who were just following the cues
left in the film's marketing were likely fairly
turned off by what they saw.
Stiff competition
Choosing the perfect release date can be all-important
to a film's success, and studios will occasionally
shift around titles based on what other companies
are scheduling.
This was the case with Mother, which saw its
planned October release moved up a month to
avoid competing with Happy Death Day.
And while that might've saved them from going
up against that movie's crowd, it did end
up pitting the pic against Stephen King's
It, which defied all expectations at the box
office and continued to draw in audiences
for its second weekend.
Rather than trying out something they didn't
understand and no one seemed to like, moviegoers
seemed to take the safe bet for their weekend
thrills by hitting up It, which had a lot
more word of mouth buzz.
Wide release washout
Despite the big stars attached, Mother is
ultimately an arthouse film, and one that
really isn't designed for a wide audience.
Paramount Pictures might've been looking at
the potential dollar signs when putting Mother
out to more than 2,300 theaters right away,
but in hindsight, it might've fared better
by seeking limited release first.
The strategy to put a niche film on a limited
theatrical run first before expanding was
exactly what worked for Aronofsky's Black
Swan, which was similarly eerie and stirred
up its fair share of audience confusion at
the end, too.
But because of the cultural must-see moment
that was produced by Natalie Portman's performance
in the pic, enough buzz justified getting
it into more theaters and the movie turned
a nice profit as a result.
Perhaps a slower roll-out could've saved Mother
from being lashed at by audiences right away
to kill any momentum the movie might've earned
by creating such a conversation among critics.
Thanks for watching!
Click the Looper icon to subscribe to our
YouTube channel.
Plus check out all this cool stuff we know
you'll love, too!